Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Dieser bill gates der sagt ja alles voraus gibt's irgendwas was dir noch nicht vorher gesagt hat.
Das internet.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihunderteinundvierzig frisch auf den tisch am achtzehnten,
achtzehnten april im jahre des chorona virus ja.
Im ersten jahr des corona wir.
Ja irgendwie lustigen witz gelesen mit dem zeitreisenden der so kommt so welches jahr ist ja zwanzig zwanzig oh das erste jahr,
der langen zeit.
Kommen wir zum feedback oder müssen wir noch irgendwas anderes sagen.
Auf keinen fall.
Wir wurden darauf also es wurde mir wurden über windows,
ja auch linux tastatur kürze aufgeklärt und zwar kontroll-ct in diesem modernen grafischen umgebungen
wird verwendet um sachen zu kopieren und.
Nur bei windows nicht in den modernen grafischen umgebung.
Auf meinem linux ist es tatsächlich auch so wobei in der regel schriftsteller c weil im terminal ja steuerung c belegt ist aber das sind details,
es ist tatsächlich so dass julia räder dann auch zugegeben hat auf twitter dass das
das kontroll-ct dann der ausschlaggebende
faktor für den namen war und nicht das traditionelle control was ist schon sehr viel länger gibt glaube ich.
Deutlich heißt auch auf text in askia.
Du ich nehme das jetzt so zur kenntnis man lernt nie aus,
dann gab es gibt es immer noch feedback ja aber die messung von bluethoothspeaker ist ja aber ungenau.
Ja deswegen ist es ja auch eine herausforderung eine corona app zu bauen.
Leider haben wir nichts besseres und leider habt ihr jetzt auch noch nix besseres erfunden,
insofern man muss glaube ich wenn man sich darüber gedanken macht auch eben erkennen wie.
Weit diese diskussion schon ist und was wir dadurch vermieden haben an an anderen
problemen die man sich hätte eintreten können wir sind hier nur mal in einer krise und ganz klar geht es bei all diesen korona tracing apps darum wirklich eine noch nie dagewesene
herausforderungen irgendwie zu stemmen die natürlich viele probleme hat es gibt eben bei problemen die einen die den ganzen tag um das problem tanzen und die anderen die wenigstens versuchen es so gut wie möglich zu
lösen mein respekt gilt meistens eher letzteren aber,
auf jeden fall ist es richtig dass es sehr gut sein kann dass ich das als zu problematisch erweist und zwar habe ich in der letzten sendung.
Ja schon es gibt zwei perspektiven über ein volk weil einer solchen app die eine perspektive ist,
es ist eigentlich kein problem wenn wir zwei millionen leute fälschlicherweise für vierzehn tage in quarantäne schicken weil wir aktuell ungefähr achtzig,
bis zweiundachtzig millionen leute ohne anlass in quarantäne schicken ja das heißt,
so gesehen wäre das selbst bei katastrophalen raten immer noch besser als das was wir jetzt machen
die andere perspektive ist die einer person die zum,
zweiten oder dritten mal fälschlicherweise in quarantäne geschickt wird zu zeiten wo andere noch draußen rumtanzen das ist natürlich ein problem
aber auch eines den man sich nähern kann und ich glaube ohnehin dass eine contact tracing app nicht wirklich,
klarkommen wird also die real welt implementierung glaube ich wird dich pingeln und dich kontakte bestätigen lassen.
Um dieser ungenauigkeit und diesen problemen rechnung zu tragen davon gehe ich aus.
Zweimal ist es am ende ein telefon und keine person so und ob man dann wirklich in quarantäne geht und gehen muss ist noch mal eine ganz ganz andere.
Leider ist das aber auch ein argument gegen pseudonymen oder anonyme ansätze denn
je nachdem wie man seinen ansatz gestaltet ja das
man das so radikal machen könnte dass man gar nicht weiß wer die anonym oder pseudonymen person war die einen eventuell angesteckt hat oder nicht je nachdem die zentrale zentral so jetzt die,
rückführung darauf wer hat mich infiziert.
Könnte also natürlich helfen oder wer hat mich mit wem hatte ich kontakt weil es könnte ja zum beispiel sein dass man sagt ach ja der willi komm ey das ist so ein schwieriger typ dann hatte ich eben meine maske auf und eine,
glasscheibe dazwischen war ich dem nicht über den weg traue oder,
in dem supermarkt hängt eine glasscheibe oder sowas ne das könnte ja sein und ich denke dass das.
In real welt implementierung einer solchen contact racing app in irgendeiner form teil manuell berücksichtigt sein wird.
Oder was denkst du tim.
Ja also ohnehin ist es halt erstmal ein ein hinweis dass man infiziert sein
könnte und bei allen modellen spielt auf jeden fall die zeit eine rolle also je nachdem welchen ansatz man da folgt wird halt mindestens der tag wenn ich sogar die uhrzeit,
was ich ganz hilfreich finde und in dem moment muss man für sich selber dann halt abschätzen okay was für ein vehement war ich da zu diesem zeitpunkt ist das etwas worüber ich mir gedanken machen muss
war ich im öpnv war ich im supermarkt dann ist es problematisch,
bei mir zu hause und hab irgendwie stundenlang netflix geguckt dann kann man das wahrscheinlich sogar ignorieren muss man sich vielleicht ein bisschen darüber gedanken machen was das jetzt sozusagen für ein kontakt gewesen sein soll aber da kommen dann halt die nachbars wand vielleicht ins spiel.
So oder so sind das immer alles noch deutliche verbesserungen zu der alternative was wir eingehend schon gesagt hast und,
ich glaube das ist auch das was ich viele leute gerade noch überhaupt nicht klar machen wir haben jetzt so ein mega bremsen lok down den wir auf gar keinen fall in dieser form,
nochmal so haben wollen.
Um das zu verhindern müssen wir uns einfach kreative gedanken machen weil ich glaube viele leben auch noch so ein bisschen in dieser illusion,
naja wenn dann der look down vorbei ist dann ist krise auch vorbei ja mitnichten das kann sein wenn wir glück haben dass uns das nur ein zwei jahre verfolgt,
pech haben sogar noch sehr viel länger,
und das ist kein zustand den wir haben wollen deswegen sollten wir alle möglichkeiten finden dass so erträglich und händelbar zu machen wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Da kann ich jetzt auch noch ein twitter witz erzählen der heute mich erreichte da war sieht die sinkende titanic abgebildet,
nicht ganz gesunken und jemand ruft time to open technik ich aussehe.
Ein sehr schöner trump bezug ja.
Fand ich den vergleich mit dem fallschirm besser wo jemand zu den falschen gezogen hat ja der falsche macht doch jetzt meinen sturz erheblich ab.
Wir brauchen die nicht mehr.
Kann ich dir jetzt abmachen so und das ist so die situation in der wir uns gerade befinden.
Okay dann haben wir in der letzten sendung über die corona datenspeicher gesprochen.
Und da hatten wir interessanterweise tatsächlich es kommt ja.
Eigentlich selten vor dass wir so gespaltenes feedback bekommen und zwar gab es einmal so feedback in die richtung da hättet ruhig mal fest dadrauf hauen können eure kritik ist so zurückhaltend.
Und von anderen kam die das feedback war dir aber voll gemein zu der app so das ist ja trotzdem vielleicht auch ganz schön.
Im c verfahren wir ja grundsätzlich nach dem prinzip erst dann guck aber da wir jetzt am samstag aufnehmen könnte es sein dass wenn ihr diese sendung hört,
es vielleicht schon neueres in der angelegenheit gibt dass es könnte zum beispiel sein dass ich irgendjemandem mal genauer angeschaut hat was glaube ich.
Ohnehin inzwischen,
bekannt ist also zumindest mir lange genug dass ich jetzt davon ausgehe dass es nicht geheim war kennst du das tim wenn du so wenn diese drückerkolonne mit den,
mit den fotos von tierbabys die stehen beim alexanderplatz stehen die gerne mal ne die haben dann irgendwie fotos von tierbabys und sagen er gibt es fünf euro hier für diesen kleinen hund ne und der trick ist ja so,
du gibst fünf euro aber monatlich und die sagen dir nicht wie man,
die los wird das heißt die fünf euro summieren sich auf sechzig im jahr und auf jenachdem,
wie lange du noch hast sehr viel mehr geld als die fünf euro die du da verstanden hast so ungefähr ist das auch bei der datenspeicherung.
Denn bei den.
Also was die außer bei apple health sich bei.
Zum beispiel google fit holen also sie haben ja anbindung für verschiedene geräte ich spreche jetzt über den fall google fit und auch.
Ich glaube bei gaumen ist das ebenfalls so aber wie gesagt zumindest in dem fall die holen sich,
talks für eine app das heißt es ist gar nicht die app,
die die daten an das gibt sondern die holen sich die selber aus eurer cloud und die primär funktion der app ist es in diesen fällen nur den cloud zugriff einmal einzurichten mit eben,
diesen.
Die app selber macht also gar nichts das hat übrigens auch zur folge wenn du die app installiert ist es nicht so als würde der of token dann ungültig,
also du hast dann wie nennt man das so ein dauerauftrag ne,
auftakt einzugs ermächtigung eine eindruck ermächtigung ist das ja,
nico corona einzeln so und das hat natürlich auch leider so ein paar folgen für deine pseudonymen täte also das ist alles.
Boah da weiß ich nicht ob ich das so besonders gut heißen kann aber ich fand's ganz schön,
da mal geteiltes feedback zu bekommen es.
Wir müssen in all diesen bereichen und ich glaube das muss ich jetzt auch mal so vielleicht grundsätzlich sagen.
Ihr erkennt ja zum beispiel dass wir hier diese contact tracing apps auch sehr interessiert und,
bisweilen wohlwollend beachten betrachten und genauso.
Kann man sicherlich auch sich über diese datenspuren app.
Wohlwollend unterhalten denn von der gesamtidee her ja hat man wahrscheinlich niemals seine fitness daten,
an irgendetwas besseres gegeben als hier ein paar forscher die sind was weiß ich in wie vielen clouds die landen mit mit irgendwelchen,
abnehmen apps und sieben minuten workout apps und was ihr euch alles installiert ja die sind überall verteilt wahrscheinlich haben die daten noch nie so eine gute anwendung bekommen zum beispiel.
Auch bei euch nicht ja also ihr sammelt ja im zweifelsfall auch nur diese daten ohne euch jetzt sage ich mal in in der tiefe der analyse mit diesen daten wirklich zu beschäftigen insofern ist das.
Wahrscheinlich noch eine der besten eine besten anwendungszeit wecke für diese daten die diesen daten jemals passiert,
nichtsdestotrotz muss eine solche app wie jede andere app auch mit der gebotenen sorgfalt gebaut werden.
Und bleiben da die jetzt mich ja fast vom stuhl gefallen ja das landet alles hier in meinen hälfte an.
Vom konto abgebucht.
Und das ist.
Die ansprüche an it-sicherheit und privatsphäre oder datenschutz bleiben natürlich auch in diesen fällen bestehen und.
Sie sind ja aber auch ja der der nicht der krise sondern der krisenbewältigung der krisenbewältigung,
insofern schauen wir da mal weiter wohlwollend drauf.
Vierhunderttausend leute haben das installiert sagte dass er nach ein paar tagen.
Vierhunderttausend jetzt schon.
Das schon ein paar tage her die zahl was nicht wie sich das entwickelt hat aber es ist auch nicht so dass das jetzt gar keine freunde gefunden hat so viel auch schon mal zum thema werden den tracing apps überhaupt installiert werden von leuten so.
Kann schon sein.
Naja vierhunderttausend für so eine app noch ein bisschen zu wenig ne.
Ja aber in den ersten tagen.
In heinsberg wäre das eine ganze menge.
Da reden wir gleich noch drüber.
Da kommen wir gleich zu kaum feedback gab es zu logbuch freiheit
außer dass mir jemand einen klugen tipp gegeben hat wie man
seinen youtube account verifiziert insofern gibt es jetzt die folge eins versammlungsfreiheit im look down auf youtube und
auch die folge zwei die ja morgen am sonntag um sechzehn uhr premiere hat wird für viele von euch,
dann schon erhältlich sein,
insofern könnt ihr euch da zwei folgen logbuch freiheit anschauen und ich freue mich über feedback ich habe natürlich,
youtube kommentare deaktiviert ich bin ja kein idiot aber ich freue mich wenn ihr das feedback zum beispiel hier in den sendung kommentaren.
Zurücklasst oder auch unter meinem kontaktformular ich bin da ja oder wir beide sind da ja sehr neu da drin die lea und ich ansonsten klar please like share subscribe mai youtube kanal,
da gibt's schöne sachen.
Du hast die glocke vergessen klar alter ohne glocke bist du nix auf you.
Glocke ach ja genau man muss die glocken man muss die glocke machen damit ihr damit ihr eine push-notification kriegt.
Richtig ran bimmeln genau ansonsten muss ich nochmal betonen dass dass das natürlich mit logbuch netzpolitik gar nichts zu tun hat ja weil bin ich ja nicht dabei ja.
Richtig deswegen heißt auch logbuch freiheit.
Ist was ganz anderes.
Ach so.
Nur zufällig weil du da auch bist hat es überhaupt bezug.
Habe ich da kann ich ja wohl die hälfte die die hälfte von dem namen kann ich ja wohl mitnehmen.
Aber doch nicht den ich bitte dich.
Schön war übrigens auf diesem united stream die haben ja tatsächlich auch sonst ganz gutes programm gestern habe ich mir den stream angeguckt von maroon im mensch meier geht's nochmal.
Ja na klar.
Hat mensch meier aufgelegt.
Rainbow.
Hat sie nicht gespielt ich habe da die ganze zeit die ganze zeit mit meinem grün gefärbten augenbrauen im wohnzimmer gewartet dass endlich.
Aber nichts gegen marokko ist schon eine coole sau.
So gut gemacht und die hat auch vom vom vinyl aufgelegt.
Die kann das nämlich noch so wie diese ganzen lächerlichen digital jockis.
Also kommen wir kommen wir zu den profit.
Zurück zu korona.
Zurück zu korona es gibt eine ganze reihe verschwörungstheorien.
Oh mann ja.
Über über corvette also bill gates weißt du was der jetzt gemacht hat tim.
Einen schuld.
Sau ja erstmal hat er die pandemien in seinem tattoo vorhergesagt und dann hat er die gemacht nur damit er am ende recht hatte hatte.
So läuft das heutzutage.
Der sau er verfolgt ja irgendwie den plan,
sieben verschiedene konzepte von impfstoff fabriken jetzt zu fördern in der erwartung dass höchstens ein oder zwei davon funktionieren
aber das ist die einzige möglichkeit der beschleunigung durch parallelwährung und da gibt es sagt er ja sehr schön da werden wir halt ein paar milliarden verschwenden aber das ist halt nichts im vergleich zu dem
was wir hier durch den gesamten prozess am ende einsparen werden das ist also sehr interessant dass jetzt also jemand muss echt sagen seppel geht bei microsoft weg ist wird der typ mir echt,
immer sympathischer verdammt coole sau gibt's auch übrigens diese.
Diese netflix serie bei netflix lief das glaube ich wo sie so ihn zuhause,
bisschen besuchen und du siehst irgendwie was der sich reintut und wofür der sich interessiert und so das ist schon jetzt nicht der,
nicht der schlechteste mensch ja nicht so ein schlechter mensch wie man meinen würde wenn man versucht die software zu benutzen die.
Dieser mensch in die welt gesetzt hat hatte nicht immer so ein glückliches händchen.
Ja ist schon jetzt auch ist schon durch es verjährt würde ich sagen.
Ist verjährt ja.
Andererseits zeigt aber auch
und das hat er ja eigentlich mit microsoft auch gezeigt aber kann man jetzt sozusagen im detail kritik äußern das lassen wir jetzt mal sein die witze aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so dass ihm nicht gelungen wäre aus dem nichts und weltkonzern,
aus dem boden zu stampfen und das
er fordert ja auch noch ein bisschen mehr als nur ein paar programmieren können das hat auch viel mit visionen und mit reaktionen zu tun und vor allem dass man eben auch groß denken kann und der ansatz den er jetzt hier in dieser pandemien hat.
Wünschte ich mir halt auch auf den politischen ebene den zu sehen weil das ist halt einfach professionelles denken so ja okay wir brauchen da mal ein ein impfstoff,
haben wir noch nicht ist aber durchaus denkbar dass der kommt dauert normalerweise lange,
so aber wir wissen dass ein teil von diesem lange ist halt dann das bauen der fabriken wenn wir wissen was es ist so weil jeder impfstoff braucht einen anderen prozess braucht eine komplett andere fertigungsstraße etcetera p p also bauen wir einfach mal alles,
das ist einfach geil.
Ja ich habe ehrlich gesagt den eindruck dass es bei microsoft immer so gekannt ist oder um noch einen kleinen microsoft witz.
Ich wollte gerade keinen microsoft witz mehr eigentlich gestanden ja.
Ja aber ich mache nochmal okay keine microsoft witze mehr.
Eine microsoft witze über begabtes nur über die anderen.
Aber über fünf g können wir noch witze über machen.
Na ja diese ganzen verschwörungstheorien ich meine ich ich schaust du dir das an also ich.
Ich nehme das zur kenntnis.
Ja ich nehme das bestenfalls zur kenntnis ich ich kann das nicht ertragen dass einfach dass da will ich
gar keine zeit darauf verschwinden aber ich weiß natürlich dass leute das tun und du triffst auch manchmal so leute auf der straße die einen ja ja begehrtes also hatte ich gerade gestern stand ich auf der straße mit jemandem unterhalten kam so.
Bei dir genau richtig.
So ein zeitungsverkauf er kam dann irgendwie den ich kannte weil er irgendwie immer durch die bars latscht wo ich dann bin ja weißt du so halt so ein
ja
du hast ja alles gelogen und seine große verschwörung hat er nicht gesagt aber dann kann man gleich mit bill gates begeht das ist ja ein faschist,
weißt du also würde ich gefragt so was wo wie warum war es nein,
warum und es war auch klar es sinnlos ist da irgendwie so diskutieren ich habe immer einfach nur gesagt so nee ist nicht so ja,
und es könnte dann annehmen oder nicht hat er natürlich.
Weißt du was ich schön finde tim wie der die geschichte wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade erzählt da habe ich auch wieder eingetroffen hätte konnte annehmen oder nicht.
Gesagt mir geht es kein faschist.
Schön ist gerade diese wir haben ja in der letzten sendung ja schon bezug darauf genommen irgendwie fünf dass das korona kommt ja eigentlich von fünf g.
Deswegen werden in den niederlanden und in england ja jetzt die fünf masten abgefackelt wo man auch sagen muss so,
respekt die machen sich immerhin so klug dass sie offenbar fünf masken von vier geben masten unterscheiden können oder vielleicht auch nicht ja,
auf jeden fall wo wird der quatsch verbreitet natürlich auf facebook und youtube und damit haben wir jetzt wieder so eine,
unwahrheiten debatte fake news debatte und,
die wurde ja in den vergangenen jahren insbesondere wenn es ums politische campaign ging noch ein bisschen anders
gehandelt wo sie nämlich gesagt haben ja das stimmt schon da müssen wir irgendwie was machen und so aber wenn der präsident irgendwie fake news verbreitet oder so dann.
Können wir da jetzt nicht so wirklich vielleicht haben wir einen fette checker oder sonst was aber.
Wir wissen nicht und diese maßnahmen wandern alle immer sehr soft jetzt geht es tatsächlich los dass facebook sich darüber gedanken macht sie unterscheiden hier die beiden begriffe missinformationen,
desinformation desinformation sind quasi groß angelagert angelegte desinformationskampagnen mit dem ziel,
leuten falsche dinge zu sagen und missinformationen ist jetzt der einzelne akt ja beispielsweise das sharing einer solchen informationen und sie wollen jetzt damit beginnen,
denjenigen die so etwas verbreiten ein hinweis zu geben ja zu sagen übrigens das was du da verbreitet hast das ist ist nicht so.
Bestimmt so effektiv wie ich mit dem zeitungsverkauf.
Genau deswegen gibt es jetzt auch die forderung.
Zu sagen ey sag das doch den empfänger nur nicht den verbreitern und
dann sagt facebook ja hin und her und da kommen aber dann auch der einwand naja pass mal auf für euren werbekampagne könnt den leuten bei dem werbeanzeigen auf die millisekunde genau sagen wie lange die leute drauf geschaut haben und wie viele von denen das geklickt haben also könnt ihr das mit den fake
news und sachen die da irgendwie verbreitet werden auch also es gibt ja jetzt.
Bemühungen oder eine erneute diskussion und die läuft diesmal anders als in dem falle der politischen desinformationskampagnen so da bin ich mal gespannt wie sich das
weiter entwickelt es ist natürlich ja also diese gesamte erfahrung und so bringt uns alle so ein bisschen an,
ja grenzen des der vorstellungskraft und irgendwie auch so eine frage nach kanada muss das denn alles sein und so da das haben wir alle.
Aber ich muss so jetzt auch das ist ja was was man gerade uns vielleicht selten sagen hört so.
Insgesamt bin ich schon ganz zufrieden damit wie.
Das hier grob gerade läuft ja wir haben wir haben einen ganzen haufen an problemen,
beispielsweise hier eindämmung also missbrauch der kontaktverbot e zur zur verhinderung von demonstrationen,
glücklicherweise haben wir dann aber auch da die urteile die dem wieder entgegentreten wir haben gesundheitsminister dem ich,
nicht ganz so viel zutraue aber glücklicherweise wird er irgendwie container ja also es läuft alles gerade nicht so unglaublich schlecht was nicht heißen soll dass es keine probleme gibt.
Aber wo probleme sind da sehe ich in der regel auch irgendjemanden.
Der oder die dafür sorgen dass das dann doch halbwegs sich noch in der bahn hält und seien es die gouverneure in den usa.
Ich fasse zusammen wir jammern aber wir auf eine hohe niveau.
Also habe ich schon noch den eindruck es läuft alles noch ganz okay.
Vergleich ist es auf jeden fall alles noch im lot das kann natürlich auch schnell auseinander klappen.
Genau deswegen gucken wir ja drauf.
Vielleicht noch ein tipp für verschwörungstheorien
an der backe hat oder vielleicht mal zurecht biegen will verlinke ich noch ein schönes video wo ihr der youtuber simon sehr schön in wenigen minuten mal alle facts zu fünf g schön zusammengefegt hat und,
so als argumentationshilfe nicht dass ich,
voller hoffnung dass es viel bringt aber vielleicht irgendjemand der noch zweifel hat auch noch diese auszuräumen so.
Ich sag mal so in so einem turbulenten sturm des gesprächs mit einer verschwörungstheoretiker drin oder ein verschwörungstheoretiker
ist es nicht schlecht so ein kleinen handschmeichler der realität in der hand zu halten mit einem youtube-video wo vielleicht noch 'ne zurechnungsfähig person spricht ja also das.
Handschmeichler der realität das ist schön wobei man auch in deutschland ist die argumentation eigentlich relativ einfach so ah ihr denkt dass fünf den korona virus verbreitet wir sind in deutschland gibt es keinen fünf g.
Ja
Wie soll das denn hierher gekommen seid.
Wie soll denn das funktionieren.
Hallo okay dann.
Machen wir ein kleines update zum stand der contact tracing und korona apps und zwar möchte ich jetzt.
Also wer sich da jetzt detaillierter mit auseinandersetzt hat vielleicht auch mitbekommen dass es dass da jetzt eine reihe an,
aufregenden news gibt die dann doch irgendwie inhaltlich relativ schwach sind das heißt,
in der spezifikationen ebene und technisch hat sich da jetzt relativ wenig getan deswegen möchte ich jetzt mal eine metaperspektive auf das geschehen wagen und zwar es gibt ja im prinzip.
Drei player in diesem bereich contact racing apps das ist einmal der staat selber.
Und das ist einmal also google apple die großen monopole dir jetzt auch also von denen halt diese geräte stammen.
Oder die betriebssysteme die darauf laufen und dann gibt es noch,
dritte die ich jetzt sagen wir mal als ich nenne jetzt mal dritte beziehungsweise je nachdem.
Auch treuhänder die sagen okay wir,
trauen den staaten nicht wir trauen auch den big nicht deswegen sind wir hier als,
treuhänder die dafür sorgen dass es irgendwie eine privatsphäre basierte
contact tracking contact tracing möglichkeit gibt die wir implementieren die wir bauen wie auch immer ja also unabhängig davon ob das jetzt den trail oder dezentral ist das ist also diese unabhängige dritte.
So jetzt ist das so die unabhängigen dritten die trauben start- und big technik,
start und big trauen aber auch einander nicht und die haben auch beide sehr gute gründe dafür ja also es ist.
Traditionell so dass wir versuchen unsere daten irgendwie möglichst nicht diesen big,
zu geben und vor allem auch irgendwie die staatliche souveränität nicht an,
abzutreiben und genauso kommen diese big tech-leute und sagen also diese staaten entschuldigung das sind irgendwie diese nervenden clever da unten und je nachdem wo wir unseren briefkasten aufhängen wollen die steuern von uns haben ja.
Ist irgendwie auch nervig ja und das heißt es gibt eigentlich allen diesen playern gegenüber einen argwohn und dieser argwohn ist.
Gesund ja,
so bürgerinnen trauen nämlich start und big take nicht ja und jetzt ist die einzige frage ja was ist denn eigentlich mit diesem dritten mit treuhänder ja und da findet natürlich so ein bisschen diese diskussion gerade statt über
zentrale und dezentrale systeme nochmal zur allgemeinen auffrischung.
Für die unterscheidung zwischen zentral und dezentral ist,
die frage entscheidend wo die jetzt kommt das jetzt kommt zu so auf die entscheidung dann vor also für die unterscheidung von zentral und dezentral,
ist die frage relevant wo die entscheidung zu alarmierung getroffen wird im dezentralen ansatz wird sie auf deinem gerät getroffen im zentralen ansatz auf einem zentralen server der,
auf dem dann eben auch,
kontakt grafen anfallen also im im zentralen ansatz weiß ein server gerät xy alarmiert jetzt folgende fünf drei oder acht geräte.
Es geht allerdings keinen mir bekannten zentralen ansatz der jetzt in europa diskutiert wird oder in deutschland diskutiert wird wo,
unmittelbar klar wäre welche person das ist aber das ist so der der darüber streiten sich eben gerade die gelernten masse das dezentrale masters zentral zu den dezentralen ansätzen
gehören primär d p t welche,
ursprünglich auch in peppi.
Mit drin waren in p t dem europäischen ansatz sollte es eine zentrale und eine dezentrale möglichkeit geben.
Dazu komme ich gleich nochmal wichtig ist steht für einen dezentralen ansatz ein anderer dezentrale ansatz ist das was apple und google,
vorgeschlagen haben.
Die dezentralen ansätze haben den vorteil dass sie so die höchste privacy bieten und damit eben auch das höchste vertrauen.
Die höchsten grund dem zu vertrauen jetzt muss man da natürlich auch wieder.
Einschränkungen machen ja unter der annahme dass ich genau weiß was das tut und das von unabhängigen dritten betrieben wird sie ja,
da unterscheiden sich dann nur drei und apple google so ein bisschen ja die ist open source apple google hat ein konzept dargelegt aber da komme ich gleich nochmal darauf zu,
der vorteil von diesen dezentralen ansetzen ist es gibt keine kontaktgranaten.
Der nachteil ist es gibt keine kontaktgranaten für epidemiologische forschung entscheidungsfindung und monitoring,
benutzen da den etwas ungünstigen begriff zur welt der natürlich in der in privatsphäre.
Und netzpolitik bereichen tatsächlich eine sehr andere konsultation hat warum interessiert die epidemiologische und epidemiologische der kontakt graf nun die sagen.
Es wäre gut zu wissen wie viele leute an jedem tag alarmiert wurden wie sich diese zahl im laufe der zeit ändert,
grundsätzlich ginge das auch in einem dezentralen modus diese zahl zurück zu liefern aber da hat man natürlich wieder das risiko dass man diesen,
dezentralen modus ein bisschen versaut denn das eigentlich das eins der einzige grund warum man diesem dezentralen modus macht ist damit es keine kontakt grafen gibt und.
Hätten den ihr zeit gerne ein weiterer also je nachdem wie man darauf blickt ist das jetzt ein vorteil oder nachteil aber darüber streiten sie sich gerade ein wie ich denke,
der entscheidendste nachteil der dezentralen ansätze aber ist dass das tuning schwieriger wird man hat kaum feedback,
und kann deshalb schlechter lernen ja also wenn ich jetzt nicht,
wenn ich noch nicht mal weiß wie viele leute alarmiert wurden dann weiß ich auch nicht wie viele positives negatives und so weiter ich habe ich komme immer auch an diese daten,
ja aber zum beispiel ein paar tage später wenn wenn die leute sich dann selber melden oder unter,
größeren schwierigkeiten und das heißt,
wird schwieriger die entscheidung an die vielen verschiedenen geräte die unendlich vielen situationen und kombination irgendwie anzupassen.
Und wir haben's ja hier mit einer entscheidung zu tun die die menschheit noch nicht hand hatte ja also es ist schwer davon auszugehen dass irgendjemand eine.
Corona app sich jetzt ausdenken und sagt unter folgende bedingungen alarmieren ich und diese parameter sind direkt die richtigen,
ja und bei einem dezentralen ansatz wird es schwierig dass auch im laufe der zeit anzupassen denn für dritte standards,
kann man einfach nicht so gut updaten und upgraden wie zentralisierte das ist einfach ein fakt der gefällt mir auch nicht aber es ist einer
und das beste beispiel was da immer gerne angebracht wird ist halt e-mail,
klar gibt es bessere modelle auch zur ende zu ende verschlüsselten versand von e-mail aber wir wissen alle das was am ende passiert ist dass wir.
Primär e-mails versenden die halt standards von vor weiß ich nicht,
also die man mit standards von vor ja ich weiß ich weiß nicht genau wann noch dazu kam ja dann ist ungefähr zwanzig jahre oder so aber.
Das das hat man da wirft man einmal in anker raus und den wird man nicht ganz so einfach wieder los auch da gibt es möglichkeiten aber in einem zentralen modell.
Ist das eben einfacher,
und dann gibt's noch die als problem in diesem dezentralen ansatz sie hat das schon angemerkt dass es eben datenschutzrechtlich eben da diese frage gibt im dezentralen ansatz,
markieren sich ja leute als infiziert und zwar öffentlich denn diese daten wer infizierte wer kreuz gesendet hat und dann.
Diagnostiziert wurde nur diese werden ja veröffentlicht das heißt von jedem code der da veröffentlicht wurde weiß man die person die den gesendet hat.
Ist infiziert jetzt stellt sich die frage wie gut kann man daraus wieder auf eine person schließen das sind die dinge die halt in dezentralen ansätzen gelöst werden.
Leider interessiert das
datenschutzrechtlichen argumentation ein bisschen weniger weil die sagen na ja die daten sind nun mal da und die könnten ja diesen rückschluss erlauben das heißt da gibt's nochmal diese ganze datenschutzrechtlichen problematik die gewissermaßen ja widersinnig ist weil ja weniger daten anfallen
aber diese diskussion findet eben statt.
So jetzt kommt der zentrale ansatz daher und hat erstmal den nachteil na ja er hat kontakt grafen das ist ein entscheidender nachteil ist der eine grund warum wir überhaupt die zentrale ansätze machen jetzt hat er aber leider auch ein vorteil und der vorteil ist.
Es gibt diese kontakt grafen ja und auf die,
einsichten die sich von diesen kontakt grafen und den alarmierung erhoffen,
ist zu sehen was geht denn zum beispiel in zwei wochen läuft es gerade gut oder läuft es gerade schlecht ja und wir.
Blicken ja zumindest in eine welt wo sich gedanken gemacht wird,
vielleicht genauer schneller feiner dieser ausbreitung zu begegnen ja während wir.
Nachdem hier in deutschland die kontaktspuren begonnen haben,
eben in einer zeit waren wo wir erstmal vierzehn tage darauf warten mussten um zu erkennen hilft das eigentlich was wir hier gerade machen könnte man,
unter umständen anhand von kontakt grafen da schneller sehen ob das etwas bringt weil man eben.
Lernen könnte weiterhin da die entscheidungsträger zentral liegen könnte man dort unter umständen mit weniger aufwand schneller entscheidungen einer höheren güte treffen,
das jetzt mal so das sind die,
diskussion die da jetzt gerade stattfinden gleichzeitig möchte keiner der ansätze die hier gerade diskutiert werden.
Und das ist weder google apple noch irgendwie noch,
d p t und diese alle heißen irgendeine zentrale identifizierung von personen sammeln von gesundheitsdaten das möchte niemand in diese debatte ist dann jetzt apple und google sind reingekommen in einer ja doch auch irgendwie,
einmaligen aktion aber irgendwie paper veröffentlicht haben wo ihre beiden logos drin sind und sagen okay wir vereinheitlichen das jetzt.
Wir sagen jetzt wo der hase lang läuft und geben vor und die haben sich für einen dezentralen ansatz,
entschieden und die vorteile davon sind es gibt eine vereinheitlichung wie das überhaupt einfach mal weltweit funktionieren kann ja das ist ja irre leistung ja.
Und.
Wahrscheinlich wichtigste vorteil ist naja die können es in ihrer betriebssysteme integrieren und dann kann es auch tatsächlich funktionieren das ist natürlich auch die macht mit der die ja in diesem feld agieren,
und jetzt kommt der nachteil die machen das zwar dezentral und aber auf der,
us-air und da kennen sie die identität der person ja ohnehin jetzt gehen geben sie natürlich wieder in ihren kryptografisch beschreibungen so zeigen sie wie sie dieses problem lösen wollen aber am ende,
gerade in so einem apple bereich ist das dann close source und wir fallen auf vertrauen zurück.
Und da kommt natürlich jetzt wieder dieser punkt so vertrauen wir big vertrauen wir starten und da in zwei sich jetzt der zwist der eigentlich gerade stattfindet denn.
Dadurch durch diese vereinheitlichung und durch die macht die google und apple hier haben degradiert ihr ansatz im prinzip.
Staaten zu kunden die haben die staaten verlieren jede souveränität darin irgendwie sich zu überlegen so und so wollen wir contact racing machen sondern es gibt halt contact racing.
Und da gibt's von google und apple wie alles andere auch und.
Gleichzeitig degradiert google und apple damit so app anbieter also die dritten und treuhänder,
dazu dass sie ein bisschen klicke bounty für die epic machen können und sich um das regulatorische heavy lifting kümmern können,
ja also google und apple hatten natürlich kein interesse mit allen ich weiß nicht wie viel es gibt hundertsechzig staaten dieses planeten darüber zu reden unter welchen bedingungen von wem signiert irgendwie jemand dann als infiziert
gilt oder nicht ja damit haben wir natürlich keine lust sich auseinanderzusetzen mit anderen worten seine hier pass auf wir geben euch auf der us hier das ding
ja und dann möglichst geben uns dann die staaten.
Sagen dann okay wie läuft wohin die daten kommen und welche apps wir irgendwie zulassen können und welche nicht und unter welchen bedingungen so dann.
Den sagen wir mal den ärgerliche kram den könnt ihr selber machen ja so ist eigentlich gerade die lage und da ist da beginnt jetzt das große tauziehen und.
Mir scheint es so zu sein dass eben.
Was hier gerade passiert die staaten trauern big technisch traut den staaten nicht und die ziehen natürlich alle daraus ihre schlüssel nämlich gibt die daten lieber uns und.
Die regierung haben immerhin das,
also die europäischen regierungen haben immerhin das problem bewusstsein dass sie sagen okay wir wissen selber dass wir diese daten nicht kriegen können wir wollen aber auch gar nicht haben wir wollen ja nur sicherstellen dass unsere,
national health instituts was weiß ich dass er oder wer auch immer darauf zugreifen kann um uns dann irgendwie bei den maßnahmen zu beraten deswegen zerren die großen europäischen staaten deutschland frankreich.
Sehr eindeutig und lesbar in richtung zentraler modelle.
Und haben einen allgemeinen wenn auch technisch wenig nachvollziehbaren je nach betrachtungsweise arg wo gegenüber einer lösung von google und apple.
Das scheint mir die allgemeine gemengelage zu sein und,
das finde ich auch dass viel interessantere tauziehen was da gerade stattfindet neben irgendwelchen zankereien zwischen irgendwelchen forschungsgruppe die dann da ja sich alle nicht angemessen verhalten.
Und da bin ich sehr gespannt wie das ausgeht.
Ja ich muss ja also alles richtig was du sagst man muss auch mal festhalten zum aktuellen zeitpunkt gibt es halt,
zumindest jetzt aus dieser perspektive deutschland heraus international habe ich das jetzt nicht so verfolgt wo noch weitere propose gemacht werden es gab ja schon andere ansätze in singapur etcetera die sicherlich,
mit der technischen basis die dort gefunden wurde jetzt nicht besonders zukunftsträchtig sind
aber alles was jetzt mit dieser ganzen bluetooth energy diesen beacons idee spielt.
Da gibt's die beiden großen konzeptidee die du gerade beschrieben hast ne zentral dezentral beides irgendwie versucht anonym zu sein das dezentrale hat,
prinzip bedingt da eben seine vorteile und die von dir genannten nachteile.
De facto haben wir aber heute nur für diese dezentralen sowohl eine spezifikation,
als eben auch schon die ankündigung einer implementierung mit dem extra plus das ist eben auch noch und google sind die das machen und dadurch dass sie das ins us machen das dadurch überhaupt erst ermöglichen,
während dem diese server varianten die die staaten jetzt offensichtlich ganz gerne lieber hätten weil sie sich davon mehr versprechen.
Muss auch betonen sie versprechen sich davon mehr ob sie davon auch am am ende auch mehr haben werden steht noch mal auf ein ganz anderen blatt.
Gelten diese argumente die du genannt hast aber kann auch sein.
Dass ein dezentrales modell was jetzt technisch gut durchstartet was vielleicht auch,
auf einem globalen standard arbeitet sehr schnell auch nachgerüstet wird in in in dieser hinsicht und diese anderen probleme auch löst was weiß ich die apps,
aus den einzelnen staaten werden ja sowieso so ein sonderstatus haben weil nur die dürfen überhaupt auf diese funktion zugreifen das hält nicht so dass jetzt jeder im app store irgendwie so eine app baut sondern es geht hier tatsächlich um eine app oder vielleicht auch ein set von apps
die aber alle quasi von dem national health organisation abgesegnet und herausgegeben werden und nur die machen das.
Und wenn diese apps dann,
laufen und das problem haben dass sie eben nicht schnell genug aktualisiert werden
was du ja auch gesagt hat ist man will den algorithmus ändern wie stellt man sicher dass es eben auch schnell auf allen telefon so ist weil er muss ja alle erstmal irgendwie ein update button glücken drücken durchaus vorstellbar dass wir an der stelle so ein punkt sehen werden wo,
apps einfach aktualisiert werden ja wo die betriebssysteme so ein push durchgeben und sagen diese app machen wir jetzt einfach mal aktuell
da warten wir jetzt nicht auf den user sondern wir stellen einfach sicher die aktualisieren sich bevor die irgendwie weitermarschieren können alles technisch möglich alles.
In sichtbaren bereich und auch diese ganzen epidemiologische geschichten werden sicherlich in dieser hinsicht auch noch abgefedert werden können das also jetzt sozusagen die situation staaten hätten gerne server.
Haben aber zumindest öffentlich.
Nichts vorgelegt ich kenne nichts vielleicht gibt's schon irgendwo was ich habe nichts gesehen ja es gibt keinen so soll das protokoll sein so soll 's genau funktionieren sonst alles so ja und im prinzip die dezentralen sind spezifiziert,
werden vermutlich ab mitte mai auch schon funktional sein und sind dann erstmal in der welt kann auch sein dass wir beides sehen werden.
Ich werde jetzt gar nicht so überrascht wenn man sagt okay dezentral hat vielleicht irgendwelche nachteile in puncto auswertbar keit,
ist aber schnell am start zu bringen.
Entschuldigung wenn ich da ganz kurz einhaken das war ja und ist auch nach meiner nach meinem verständnis wahrscheinlich immer noch
das ziel von zwei modelle zu erlauben deswegen waren ja war ja diese forschungsgruppe in pep.
Drin aber,
ich habe ja auch gerade schon gesagt deswegen will ich gar nicht in irgendwelche details gehen ich weiß es geht hier eher um eine meter gemenge lager und was sich in dieser meter gemengelage zeigt ist dass.
Seid google und apple da quasi ein flog in den boden gerammt haben.
Vielen anderen eben der gestaltungsspielraum weggenommen wird das kann etwas gutes oder etwas schlechtes sein deswegen habe ich das jetzt erstmal so neutral geschildert und,
um einfach mal hier die kräfteverhältnisse zu zeigen.
Ich wollte wird das jetzt auch gar nicht neutral darstellen ich sage einfach nur da
das ist sozusagen derzeit die situation wir haben diesen technischen vorsprung im im bereich dezentral sehr wahrscheinlich dass da demnächst was ins rollen kommt
wir haben den wunsch server zu machen wo derzeit noch nicht klar ist wie es ist ich finde es schließlich aber auch nicht aus also es kann auch sozusagen beides stattfinden.
Man muss dann schon also das was du im technischen vorsprung bei dezentral nennst ist jetzt
lässt sich am ende darauf unterbacher dass apple und google da mitspielen würden ja das ist ja nicht unbedingt ein technischer vorsprung ist ja nicht so als wären
zentrale ansätze jetzt untätig und würden nicht auch code schreiben und wenn du ein.
Im zweifel simplere protokoll baust was aber wo es zumindest anlass,
zu der vermutung gibt dass das unter umständen weniger gut performant ist,
in verschiedenen zielgruppe dann ist es halt auch schwierig von einem technischen vorsprung zu sprechen so einfach ja also nicht alles was einfacher ist es deshalb direkt ein technischer vorsprung.
Ich wollte in zeitlichen vorsprung.
Ok ja das.
Nicht im sinne von besser sondern der vorsprung ist da das existiert bereits es ist ist es spezifiziert es befindet sich gerade eine umsetzung und wird in wenigen wochen in auf die ein oder andere art und weise in der welt sein es wird schneller da sein.
Das ist der vorsprung den ich meinte.
Ok jedenfalls ist das gerade die große gemengelage und ich finde das jetzt sehr interessant zu sehen wer sich da am ende durchsetzen wird weil mehr als,
was jetzt irgendjemand spezifiziert hat ist tatsächlich jetzt die frage dass da doch eben andere interessen und ein kraftmessdosen reinkommt,
und das wird dann jetzt doch noch spannender als ich dachte.
Wenn das jetzt dann doch zu einem showdown zwischen big und,
starten wird die sich beide vom jeweils anderen offenbar in ihre souveränität reingegraben fühlen und auch beide finde verständlich argumente erfahren,
also das beobachte ich mit mit interesse.
Ich habe übrigens falls sich jemand für die technischen details,
interessiert in der letzten folge diese ganzen dezentralen ansatz mal im detail durchgeackert sodass man da mal nachvollziehen kann wie das dann,
funktionieren könnte.
Hatten wir glaube ich prinzipiell in locker und netzpolitik vor drei folgen oder so auch gemacht,
gut kommen wir zum nächsten thema und zwar denke ich das nächste was uns hier als diskussion.
Anstehen wird ist die,
ungleichmäßig verteilung von corona nachteilen in der gesellschaft ich hatte das ja eingangs schon so ein bisschen gesagt wir haben jetzt irgendwie gerade haben wir alle gleichermaßen
gleiche nachteile und das ist für gruppen immer quasi einfacher zu ertragen also du du erträgst.
Quasi schlechte situationen.
Umso besser je mehr leute auch in dieser situation sind ja dann gibt's nämlich kaum jemanden dem du dem du.
Den du beneiden kannst gibt es auch sehr schöne forschung zu sagen wir im bereich der.
Soziologie oder sozialpsychologen.
Dass ein besonderer also ein guter garant oder ein guter preditor für irgendwie unzufriedenheit soziale unruhen oder oder auch allgemeine unglücklichkeit.
Ist nicht unbedingt,
ob es den leuten jetzt schlecht geht oder gut geht sondern wie unterschiedliches den leuten geht also wie ungleichmäßig reichtum privilegien und sonstiges in der gesellschaft verteilt sind und zwar,
einfach nur die spannbreite und.
Das kann man sich relativ einfach an so verdeutlichen an.
So experimenten wo leute gefragt wurden pass auf du kannst du kriegst eine wohnung mit hundertzwanzig quadratmeter in einer welt wo alle anderen zweihundert haben,
oder du kriegst eine wohnung mit neunzig quadratmetern in einer welt wo alle anderen sechzig haben ja und die leute sagen ey pass auf dann nehme ich lieber die quadratmeter obwohl er ist der de facto die kleinere wohnung ist,
aber der relative wert ist für sie hat,
interessanter so worauf will ich hinaus bleiben wir bei dieser corona app sagen wir mal die schick dich in in karate-do.
In eben einer welt wo du dann nicht einer von sohn soviel achtzig millionen deutschen bist die zu hause bleiben müssen sondern wo du einer von einer million bis während alle anderen
achtzig millionen da draußen tralala machen denn ist das um einiges schwieriger zu ertragen.
Das ist der eine punkt zweitens die immunität gegen diese solche wird zu einem.
Auf jeden fall zu einem privileg einen massiven privileg in dieser gesellschaft wobei übrigens hier vorsichtig kurze geschäftsidee nicht nachmachen ich erwähne die nur damit es hier zuerst gehört habe geschäftsidee corona hotel.
Funktioniert folgendermaßen die hotels haben ja grade alle quasi zu weil kaum jemand reist jetzt machst du den corona hotel
wie funktioniert also wer kommt brauchen gesundheitspark ähnlich wie irgendwie vorm fallschirmspringen tauchen oder fliegen oder sowas ne gesundheitspark dass du so grob
halbwegs in ordnung bis ärztin hat einmal geguckt dass du ein und ausatmen kannst und irgendwie kurse kopf oder so ne jo jetzt kommst du mit dem gesundheitsminister hin
und dann unterschreibst du so ein waver wie wie beim was weiß ich tätowieren piercen oder sonst was ne wo du sagst hier
oder sterbehilfe oder so ne wurde sagst du ich weiß was hier passiert ich bin im vollbesitz meiner geistigen kräfte und ich werde euch nicht verklagen und dann gibt es
die in diesem corona hotel gepflegte korona suppe die korona suppe,
wird bei exakt perfekten temperaturen für so einen korona virus gehalten und besteht aus zweifelsfall spucke und spot rum.
Von corona erkrankten und jetzt,
die steht da vorbereitet und dann kannst du davon was nehmen ja infiziert dich jetzt im corona hotel,
gezielt mit corona außerdem zum angebot gehört eine flatrate für den spa-bereich und weil die alle da korona haben und haben wollen.
All inclusive open-bar ja das ist ein richtig geiles hotel netflix flatrate es ist eine fette party dauert ungefähr dein aufenthalt vierzehn tage drei wochen,
notärzte sind in der nähe essen gibt's nur economy weil du schmeckst ja eh nichts wenn diese infektion funktioniert und.
So
Wo willst du hin hier mit diesem gedanken.
So und wenn das schiefgeht das geht ja nur bei relativ wenigen schief dann
fahne dich halt irgendwie hintenrum ins krankenhaus und die kosten die muss das hotel ja nicht tragen das kann man ja wieder schön die gewinne privatisieren,
kosten sozialisieren wie was gesagt haben und ich sage dir tim das ist kein kein,
also das ist ein sehr verwerfliches geschäftsmodell und das ist auch nicht für die gesellschaft tragfähig und genau deshalb wird es jemand machen.
Ich sage es gibt bald korona hotels.
Ich glaube du hast dich da nicht genug mit leuten unterhalten die das virus tatsächlich schon durchlebt haben.
Du ich unterhalte mich mit vielen davon ich unterhalte mich mit leuten die es jetzt gerade durchleben und mit leuten die schon durchlebt haben ich sage dir corona hotel wird's geben.
Gut aber worauf wolltest du denn eigentlich hinaus weil ich finde das jetzt ein bisschen nebensächlich.
Die leute werden da reingehen um um den solchen pass zu bekommen.
Und tatsächlich arbeitet irgendwie die bundesdruckerei mit der lufthansa go digital
urbino birgit oder keine ahnung irgend so ein blockchain dingens
jeans und verschiedenen anderen unternehmen und beratungsunternehmen an
konzepten für einen verlässlichen nachgewiesenen korona status zu regulation,
nicht nur im gesundheitswesen sondern auch in der wirtschaft beispiel einlass zu großveranstaltung internationale flüge einreise
wer schon mal in bestimmte länder gereist ist irgendwie in südamerika zum beispiel da musst du auch zum beispiel nachweis über eine gelbfieber-impfung mitbringen
ja ist also überhaupt nichts besonderes dass man bei einer einreise von menschen.
Ein immunstatus gegen bestimmte krankheiten verlangt und das wird bei korona natürlich auch eine rolle spielen und jetzt überleg dir,
was das bedeutet wenn von wie vielen sachen du einfach ausgeschlossen sein wirst wenn du nicht das,
korrekte corona prüfsiegel für dein immunsystem zeigen kannst.
Tja,
das wird bestimmt total gut funktionieren dieses prüfsiegel nicht falsch zu machen und nicht durch korruption an leute zu verteilen die hatte ich gar keinen anspruch darauf haben,
also da habe ich so ein bisschen meine zweifel ob das sozusagen greift aber dein punkt den verstehe ich natürlich schon es ist etwas was wir befürchten müssen ist
bisschen zu früh glaube ich noch in der ganzen diskussion weil wir derzeit einfach,
doch überhaupt gar keine erkenntnisse über immunität haben also wir wissen nicht ist die immunität gegeben ja also
hat man die auch auf jeden fall wenn man sich den virus einmal eingefangen und durchlebt hat.
Die aktuelle wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja vermutlich aber wissen tun wir das erst später weil dieser virus ist halt auch erst seit drei monaten in der welt,
und der andere frage ist selbst wenn er die mich immun macht wie lange wird diese immunität anhalten wird die.
Lebenszeit sein oder verschwindet die nach zwei jahren wieder wissen wir nicht.
Alles ja kein problem in einem solchen dingen abzudecken ja du müsstest ja im prinzip nur,
also im impfpass steht auch einfach nur drin wann du geimpft wurdest ne da steht nicht drin ist immun bist sondern da steht drin hat an dem und dem in dem mit dem tag irgendwie eine impfung gegen haste nicht gesehen bekommen und dann kann natürlich auch jedes land
selber könnte jedes land selber oder entscheiden und sagen pass mal auf wir akzeptieren nur so zu lange oder nicht also das ist schon.
Ich sage nur die machen sich da gerade darüber gedanken.
Wenn's nur eine technologie gebe mit der man sowas sicher abbilden könnte.
Ja genau denn sie versuchen's natürlich jetzt mit einer blockchain.
Die blockchain.
Genau eine blockchain und wir werden,
werden mal sehen wohin das führt weil man sich natürlich bei diesen sachen jetzt auch fragt okay will man das zentral erfassen will man es dezentral erfassen das heißt da wird man genau die gleiche debatte wieder führen.
Gibt jetzt eben verschiedene ansätze das umzusetzen und naja.
Wegen des hohen anreize des diesen immunstatus zu haben denke ich wird es da auch ein sehr hohen druck geben,
dass menschen versuchen den zu erlangen ja sei es durch fälschung sei es durch den korona haut helm sei es durch sonst was und das wird noch ein richtiges thema in der gesellschaft werden.
Auch zum beispiel in einer zeit wenn dann aus hoffentlich fällt ja am ende von aus einer von piketty fabriken im stoff ne da gehen wir jetzt einfach von aus der wird ja auch nicht
milliarden fach dort raus plumpst wie in die
welt braucht ja das heißt auch da werden wir dann wieder verteilung schwierigkeiten haben und so weiter und bei,
dingen die so hohe privilegien.
Versprechen viertes eben fälschung bemühungen geben wird es betrugs bemühungen geben und natürlich auch,
ja unlautere angebote wie man sie jetzt auch schon die ganze zeit hat ne das wird wird echt spannend und da.
Kann ich auch verstehen dass dass man sich dann sagt okay kann man kann man da nicht wirklich die modernen methoden der kryptographie nutzen.
Um einen solchen nachweis unfeld spart zu machen und natürlich kann man das die frage ist was hat das für gesellschaftliche konsequenzen.
Spannend deswegen ich sag's dir tipp corona heute.
Da brüssel berater um die idee so richtig in die welt zu kriegen.
Und ich kenne guten ich kenne richtig guten peer beraterteam.
Das sind startup von von von wie soll man das sagen ja also von namen die für sich sprechen.
Kai diekmann ja wer würde sich wer wünscht sich nicht kai diekmann in ins haus.
Extern de chefredakteur philipp jessen und dem eventmanager michael bronz unter anderem eine,
die haben irgendwie so ein social media pr start-up da irgendwie am laufen.
Und jetzt ist folgendes passiert der gute viro loge doktor strick,
doktor strick hat die sogenannte heinzberg gemacht die auf twitter ja schon sehr viel aufregung,
machte bevor sie überhaupt veröffentlicht wurde und sie wurde auch bis heute nicht veröffentlicht noch auch nicht als vorstudie oder sonst was musste aber ostern präsentiert werden und da gab es ein tweet den fand ich total herrlich ja da habe ich schon,
gedacht immer was ist denn jetzt los da gab's ein foto von dem herrn strick,
wie der an seinem schreibtisch sitzt oder an einem schreibtisch sitzt mit dem telefonhörer am ohr und einem stift in der hand ein stift,
und das foto war eindeutig gemacht mit einer guten kamera.
So ein bisschen aus position auch nicht von ihm selber denn er hat ja einen stift in der hand und ein telefonhörer und der tweet lautete.
Irgendwie so sinngemäß letzte ergebnisse zusammentragen in zwei stunden präsentieren wir die heinsberg studie wurde dir so denkst so warte mal.
Zwei stunden vor der präsentation telefonierst du dir noch ergebnisse zusammen und schreibst ihm stift auf und hast dann auch noch zeit für einen tweet und ein fotografen oder eine fotografin der passt doch irgendwie nicht ja.
Stellt sich raus der hat sich.
Diese story maschine berater an bord geholt mit dem ziel,
der wissenschaftlichen arbeit groß größtmögliche öffentlichkeit und sichtbarkeit zu ermöglichen
weil sich ja überhaupt niemand in diesem land gerade für corona interessiert oder irgendwelche studien das ist ja es ist unglaublich schwierig dafür aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen da brauchst du natürlich
irgendwelche berater von kai diekmann in der hütte die irgendwelche fotos für dich twittern.
Also ich man kann sich wirklich nicht man kann sich echt nicht.
Vorstellen wie unglaublich nämlich das war also der fällt mir nichts mehr
zu allen und das einzige was ich dazu sagen kann ist ich hoffe dass sich alle wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler jetzt ein für alle mal hinter die ohren schreiben dass sie in ihrer karriere sich nicht die blamage,
geben wollen die sich der strick gegeben hat indem er sich mit irgendwelchen social media beratern eingelassen hat bei seiner zweifelsohne wichtigen studie,
die sicherlich irgendwann auch noch veröffentlicht wird aber das ist auch wirklich was war das denn für eine peinliche nummer.
Es gibt da zwei faktoren glaube ich die die theoretisch hier zu zur wahrheit führen können die ich nicht kenne wann ist eine ist,
er war so blöd,
und hatte wirklich einfach nur keine lust auf die ganze öffentlichkeitsarbeit weil das ja so viel zeit kostet er möchte sich ja gerne um seine studie kümmern und deswegen war
dann dieses angebot ganz recht mit ach ja ihr öffentlichkeitsarbeit das könnt ihr ja wir sind ja auch gut
gute freunde dann ach und ihr macht das auch noch kostenlos wie nett von euch das könnte ja wirklich behilflich sein und dann ist er sozusagen
in diese realität reingelaufen das halt so eine maschine einfach funktioniert wie eine maschine das aber das,
eigentlich zu dem was er tut in der zeit in der es tut nicht passt,
das ist aber mal die freundliche auslegung die weniger freundliche auslegung ist dass das ganze
eine konzertierte aktion war dass es eine sehr bewusste entscheidung war sich dementsprechend begleiten zu lassen weil es von vornherein von dem interesse geleitet war
dieser studie in ihrem ergebnis ein spin mitzugeben,
konkret eben mit diesem argument mit ach guck mal was bei uns hier rauskommt ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm da können wir ja auch mal wieder die wirtschaft aufmachen in nordrhein-westfalen wo ein ministerpräsident ist der gerade gerne c d u vorsitzender werden möchte.
Und du hast ja mit pavel in uk w darüber gesprochen dass die,
zahlen die da raus gekommen sind für diese für diese dorf geangelt.
Irgendwie aus aus jeglichem bisherigen bisher berichteten rahmen fallen was.
Ja das ist noch ein bisschen umstritten also wir haben da auch feedback bekommen es wird das mal ein bisschen offen halten ob die nur wirklich komplett aus dem rahmen fällt aber es ist eh klar dass einfach
dieser bereich nicht aussagekräftig sein kann für ganz deutschland ja gerade weil er eben so massiv betroffen war und es ist interessant sicherlich was dabei rauskommt und man wird vor allem erstmal abwarten müssen was die zahlen am ende sind
wenn auch mal klar ist wieder die die gewichtung ist aber gut fühlt sich das nicht an.
Also in dubio pro rio im also im zweifelsfall ich gehe davon aus dass der.
Eine wissenschaftlich,
haltbare studie da vorlegen wird die wie jede andere wissenschaftliche studien ist auch ihre limitationen haben wird.
Das ist glaube ich völlig normal und in deswegen werden die limitationen in in den veröffentlichungen
offen und ehrlich diskutiert und deswegen werden studien vollständig veröffentlicht was da passiert ist mit einer vorfall zu ostern und bis heute haben wir die studie nicht gesehen das ist,
außerst peinlich und betont einfach nur warum wissenschaft seit vielen,
ich wollte heute mal sogar tatsächlich herausfinden seit wann aber auf jeden fall seit vielen hundert jahren so funktioniert ja das
wer etwas behauptet immer zeigen muss und so dokumentieren muss dass alle anderen das nachvollziehen müssen jede studie die du machst muss so beschrieben werden dass
sie die leserin in die position versetzt die gleiche studie ebenfalls durchzuführen.
Und das ist hier bis heute nicht der fall und ich hoffe dass das also ich hoffe dass der eine besonders herausragende großartige studie vorliegt weil,
es gibt nur einen grund warum ich das hoffe weil wir es uns nicht erlauben können dass jetzt ernsthafte zweifel an der,
integrität der führenden wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dieses planeten entsteht nur deshalb hoffe ich dass der typ selber ist mir völlig egal aber ich hoffe dass der am ende eine.
Vernünftige studie vorlegt die dem schloss vorschuss vertrauen dass er da erhalten hat gerecht wird.
Und ich hoffe dass alle daraus lernen wie man sich als,
ehrbarer wissenschaftler damit ins ins knie schießen kann wenn man sich mit kai diekmann einlässt denn ganz ehrlich vorsichtige these ich glaube es hat kein mensch auf diesem planeten jemals nicht bereut
sich mit kai diekmann eingelassen zu haben und wenn sie es bis jetzt noch nicht bereut haben dann ist es eben noch nicht zu ende,
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass irgendein mensch auf diesem planeten sagt ich habe mich mit auf dem diekmann eingelassen war völlig in ordnung völlig okay,
das ist gibt's einfach nicht ja das weiß man auch man lässt sich mit denen nicht ein unter keinen umständen jemals und das hat er arme herr streck jetzt auch gelernt.
Gut damit sind wir glaube ich mit dem corona thema erstmal durch für diese woche.
Ja und auch bald am ende der sendung ne.
Also wir haben es gibt ja eine app mit dem namen zoom der eine klare corona gewinner.
Und da haben wir über eine reihe an schwachstellen berichtet und über unter anderem auch darüber dass sie datenschutz mängel hat weil sie nämlich,
trecker.
In ihrem code eingebaut hatte irgendwie facebook kontaktieren und sowas die nirgendwo dokumentiert waren ja was nach unserer allgemeinen.
Datenschutzrechtlichen auffassung nicht geht wenn du eben irgendwelche für partys da mit daten fütterst muss das in der datenschutzerklärung erwähnt sein.
So stellt sich raus ein open source projekt welches.
Du empfohlen hast.
Wo ich server für betreibe genau dafür gibt es auch eine app die das gleiche problem,
und interessanterweise gibt es da wohl auch kein problem bewusstsein und zwar wurde uns in den kommentaren wurden wieder auf ein,
gitarre
aufmerksam gemacht von alba freude glaube ich sogar ausgelöst wo sie dann mit den entwicklern darüber streiten dass man diese tracker entweder rausnehmen oder in der datenschutzerklärung adäquat aufführen muss das betrifft aber,
eben.
Die app ja und genau deshalb will man eigentlich auch eine selfie web-app haben ja also wer c ist,
nicht perfekt aber ganz okay,
und genau deshalb will man eben open source auf eigenen servern sowas haben und genau deshalb ermutige ich ja auch alle sich ihre eigenen server aufzusetzen und die im besten fall eben auch aus dem browser zu nutzen,
nicht unbedingt über eine app.
Immerhin ist der code dieser app offenbar aufgeht hat dass man sich darüber beklagen kann bei summe ist das nicht der fall,
nur um nochmal bei zoom zu bleiben thorsten hat sich zoom angeschaut.
Primär weil ihnen das geärgert hat dass dass die leute das das ding benutzen trotz aller warnungen und.
Also thorsten schröder.
Thorsten schröder genau,
der bei uns ja auch einmal bisher sendungsmast war mit dem ich schon den ein oder anderen vortrag beim kongress gehalten habe und
ja hat einfach nur mal statisch in das bein geguckt finden sich irgendwelche alten open libraries drin mit schwachstellen finden sich,
die statements werden einfach konkrete nate also du hast keine prepaid statements sondern die bauen sich irgendwelche strings und werfen die dann in ihre datenbank mit anderen worten wahrscheinlich
angriffsfläche für jacksons dann hat er noch ein buffet gefunden in der logik funktion
auch das nicht ganz so geil und ja das ding bleibt halt einfach irgendwie eine wurst.
Auf welcher plattform hat er sich das angeschaut.
Das ist die windows dass die das windows beinahe zweiunddreißig bitte warum auch immer die den code als zweiunddreißig und nicht als vierundsechzig mit wahrscheinlich weil sie sonst die ganzen kaputten alten libraries nicht mehr da reingelegt kriegen.
Ja also das das bleibt ein ein fass ohne boden und jetzt muss man natürlich so sehen wenn.
Du deine schwachstelle drin hast dann betrifft die nicht unbedingt nur deine die die vertraulichkeit deiner kommunikation wenn wir hier von buffer flows und injection potenzialen reden.
Dann betrifft das eben auch die unter umständen die integrität deines rechners ne also es.
Es ist tatsächlich so ich mag viele sachen nicht als webservices ja ich mag ehrlich gesagt teilweise lieber ordentlichen code auf meinem computer.
Im falle von so einer kommunikation ist das vielleicht.
Auch so eine frage von hast du das hast du die probleme dezentral oder hast du die probleme zentral und da ist natürlich unter umständen so ein sicherheits- wie ich kontrolliere den server und.
Kontrolliere dem oder und ich muss nur auf den browser aufpassen eben ein anderes als ich habe irgendwie komische app die mir als close source irgendwie hin geschoben wird.
Aber ja das bleibt also ein ein spannendes feld und es gibt natürlich auch viele leute die jetzt bei in größeren gruppen mit jessi nicht so zufrieden sind ich höre jetzt neues gutes über von big,
button das habe ich auch mal in einer größeren gruppe genutzt das scheint da,
besser zu funktionieren gleichzeitig entwickelt sich in richtung echter ende zu ende verschlüsselung also es bleibt ein spannendes feld und wird sicherlich auch die corona krise weiterhin begleiten.
Wenn ihr sohn benutzen müsst weil es ja mal jetzt von der ganzen security geschichte abgesehen ganz gute features bietet und ich glaube bei diversen universitäten jetzt auch so die
das tool der wahl ist ne kauft euch einfach ein ipad und ballert da irgendwie das obendrauf dann kann ich zumindest der rest des rechners nicht um die ohren fliegen.
Nur empfehlen.
Ja oder ich meine man kann auch eine nehmen oder der decades rechner dafür also.
Meine ich ja bleib.
Wer ja das jetzt unbedingt ein ipad sein muss sei dahingestellt es hat natürlich einige ganz gute.
Kompakt metalisiertes funktionen andererseits würde man sich jetzt nicht ein schönes ipad damit versauen dass man da irgendwie solche sowieso.
So was so was drauf installiert ist man will ja irgendwie seine eigene umgebung auch schön halten ja du lachst.
Romantiker.
Also dein deine anspruch an software hat ja in den letzten jahren gelitten.
Klar natürlich logisch total.
Wenn ich mir die lass uns nicht mit deiner buchhaltung software anfang.
Meine buchhaltung funktioniert super ist mit deiner.
Diese software tim es gibt ja das ist.
Also was du da benutzt das sind windows interfaces wie wie sie wie man sie seit drei elf glücklich hinter sich gelassen hat das ist einfach keine experience die da geboten wird.
Aber lassen wir das.
Die auswahl so groß wäre wie ich sie gerne hätte ja das wäre schön aber die.
Der unterschied ist einfach der unterschied ist einfach dass du dich früher als du noch visionär von software gesprochen hast nicht damit zufrieden gegeben hast dass es etwas nicht gibt jetzt tust du es aber.
Das ist ja gar nicht so ich gebe mich ja überhaupt gar nicht damit zufrieden trotzdem funktioniert's und das ist erstmal das wichtigste.
Und jetzt redest du den leuten dazu sich ihre schönen ipads mit zoom voll zum ballern.
Ich habe gesagt wenn du zum benutzen musst dann kauft er zumindest ein ipad wo du das quarantäne betreiben kannst.
Wenn du zum benutzen musst dann tue etwas dagegen.
Das ist der spirit mein freund.
Ach ja tue deinen jugendlicher leichtsinn.
Was heißt hier leichtsinn ich benutze keinen zoom.
Ich bin jetzt auch kein so ich habe nur gesagt wenn ihr besuch benutzen müsst dann so.
Ich sehe wir kommen ja nicht zum ergebnis.
Der lass es lieber zum ende kommen.
Komme übrigens tatsächlich dann leute und sagen hier ich muss jetzt an der uni zum benutzen was wie kann ich mich dagegen wehrt.
Ja das ist die realität reality let's facette.
Wie gesagt früher hattest du da mehr mehr mut,
ok ich würde gerne am ende dieses corona dramas dieses arktis des corona dramas einigen leuten danken und ich hatte ja schon es gab jetzt in den letzten
sendung ja weniger dank weil ich eben psd zwei geschädigte bin.
Deswegen gibt es jetzt eine etwas längere liste und die beginnt mit besonderem dank an christoph besondere dank an harald besonderen dank an jo,
sonnentag an michael nils rüdiger besonderen dank an simon susanne und volker dann gibt es zwei unbekannte personen denen ich danken möchte.
Sie können sich gerne noch bei mir melden wenn sie ihren namen jetzt in dieser reihe vermissen.
Und dann danke ich noch in alphabetischer reihenfolge alexander andreas benjamin christian clemens daniel dirk hanno holger jens lukas
manuel marco markus martin matthias michael oliver peter philipp ralf robert,
sascha simon steffen stefan säuren thomas tore tim tobias und toni herzlichen dank.
Bitteschön endlich danke dir auch mal mir achso bisschen beruhigt.
Du warst damit nicht gemeint.
Ja genau und wie immer.
Gilt der dank auch allen ungenannten und zahlreichen daueraufträge und sonst wie supporter mutmacherin kommentierern und überhaupt all den leuten die den kopf nicht in den sand stecken,
denn das wäre nun wirklich total unangemessen.
Genau und genau was hast du jetzt ich muss likes und glocke.
Mein youtube-kanal bitte.
Ich mache ich mache es ganz klassisch ohne glocke einfach mal bei reinhören da gibt's jetzt auch einmal die woche komplettes korona update,
ohne virolent
aber mit schliff viel zeilen und interpretationen und sonstigen diskussionen was sonst noch so wichtig ist und damit entlassen wir euch in was auch immer ihr gerade meint was für ein wochentag ist ihr wisst es ja eh nicht mehr.
Stimmt's.
Tschau.
Tschüss.